Now let's look at how an attacker
can defeat the IDS so
that his attack can go undetected.
We call that an IDS performs
passive monitoring.
That is, a network IDS takes
a copy of the network traffic and
analyzes it while the traffic
is reaching the end host.
Therefore, in order for the IDS to
detect the intrusion that's happening at
the end host, he must see
the same traffic as the end host.
However, this is not always the case.
An attacker can exploit this
in order to evade the IDS.
The reason that the IDS and
the end host are seeing different
traffic is because they're using
two different operating systems that
process traffic in different ways.
In particular, TCP/IP protocol
specifications have ambiguities
that lead to different implementations
in different operating systems.
As a result, if the IDS runs on Unix and
the end host runs on Windows,
they may not process certain
packets exactly the same way.
For example,
options such as time to live or
error conditions associated
with fragments and
checksums are handled in different
ways in different operating systems.
By exploiting these evidences,
the attacker hopes that the IDS would
not see the attack traffic, yet the end
host will be affected by the attack
traffic as intended by the attacker.